Speaker 1: All right.
Let me talk about something that that happened
over the weekend.
As many of you know, when the latest Israeli-Palestinian
flare up took place at first for the first
four or so days, I. I didn't say anything
about it, feeling I didn't really have too
much to add.
I heard from some people, respectively, who
said, hey, you should talk about this.
And then so I did.
And I did a 20 minute segment over the last
month.
It's the only twenty minute segment I've done.
And that was a couple of weeks ago and throughout
before I talked about it and after the anti-Semitic
comments raining down on our YouTube channel,
raining down on Twitter, Instagram, we had
to block Twitch thousands close to a thousand
people.
I would say I don't want to exaggerate.
Certainly hundreds of people on YouTube, about
a hundred on on Twitter.
Call it six hundred to eight hundred people,
probably OK to not not be hyperbolic, which
is, you know, a lot for our program, our size.
And even after I did the segment, the anti-Semitic
comments about me being a Jew rat or all of
the different stuff, they just didn't stop.
And at a certain point, it sort of becomes
clear that you're not really contacting me
about foreign policy anymore.
It's just the anti-Semitism.
That's really what it is.
This crossed over to the real world.
And over the weekend, I was out with some
friends for dinner at at a restaurant.
And we were there sort of a lot of things
are still closing early in the Northeast because
of covid guidelines.
And so there were very few people left.
And as I was leaving, I walked by someone
who kind of gave me a weird look.
And I didn't know if it was that, you know,
I had some borscht on my face like that one
time where I did an entire show with with
borscht on my face.
And producer Pat didn't tell me or maybe they
recognized me.
I didn't really know walk past them.
And when I'm 30 feet away, I hear Pakman and
I turn around and they yell at me, you Jew,
Zionist, imperialist.
Now, I just turned and walked away, I didn't
engage with it, and I think in general what
these people want is a reaction and who knows
if they plan to film me and put it on Twitter
or whatever the case.
But I just I just walked away.
And, you know, this what's really obviously
this is not fun, but people come up to me
all the time and typically they're their positive
experiences.
And I do a show that's public.
And so to some degree, this is this is bound
to happen.
But, you know, this is this was a, quote,
left winger, right.
This is not a right winger.
This is an issue that it's more often the
left.
The right does a lot of anti Semitism with
me, but they say go back to Israel.
Right.
The right wing anti-Semitism is go back to
Israel, a place I've been once in my life
for nine days.
This is this was something from the left.
And so I think it should be clear to all of
us at this point that this is not a critique
of my position.
Right.
It's not it's not even really an argument.
As many of you know, I have more than a decade
on record of being unquestionably critical
of settlements, the Netanyahu administration,
the urgency with which we need to find a way
to lift the blockade.
I'm not going to do the segment and to see
this is the problem.
Why am I even talking about policy?
Because this incident was not about policy.
I've spoken about, you know, the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict really once in the last two years.
And so Jew, Zionist imperialist is not even
plausibly a critique of my policy.
And all sorts of things are going off here.
So what do we do about something like this?
I don't know.
I don't really plan to do anything about it.
There's a there's a real problem with anti-Semitism
on the right.
And we've covered it for a really long time.
We just reviewed on a recent live stream that
white nationalist dude who wanted Craig Cobb,
who wanted a whites only enclave in one of
the Dakotas, and he was overtly anti-Semitic
during our interview.
And that's very clearly a right wing anti-Semitism.
Unfortunately, there's a left wing anti-Semitism
as well.
And even by talking about this, there's going
to be even more that's hurled at me.
And some people are going to write and say,
well, it's not anti-Semitism, David, because
you are a Zionist.
And as I've always said before, what do you
even mean by that term?
Every time I've been confronted with it, I
never really get a straight answer.
And what I've said before is if what you're
asking me is, do I think that the solution
to the Israeli-Palestinian conflict is no
more Israel?
No, I don't think that's the solution.
Much like the solution is not.
No, no Palestinian state.
Right.
I think the solution is an Israeli state and
a Palestinian state.
Does it does that make me a Zionist?
Because otherwise it's never anything we're
we're able to actually figure out.
But hurling Jew, Zionist imperialist to someone
on the street is is over the line.
It's not a policy critique.
I don't know what else to say about it, but
if the left goes too far in this direction,
it's not going to be good.
And as I said before, it's counterproductive.
It's counterproductive because every time
Jewish folks hear about not what happened
to me, what happened to me was not violent,
wasn't physically violent, but what we believe
the videos we saw from Los Angeles, New York,
etc., more and more American Jews or Jews,
wherever they're being harassed in France,
say, wow, I really may need to move to Israel
someday.
And they disengage from holding Israel accountable
for the things Israel does wrong.
So not only do I think it's ugly and disgusting,
it's also counterproductive to what most of
these leftists claim to want.
I think that's all I really feel the need
to say about it.
Maybe something I'll follow up on at some
point in the future, but really ugly stuff
unbecoming.
Unbecoming of the left